uh you mentioned all of us have
controversies I have to ask
um uh do you find the controversy of
whether you are the sole founder or the
co-founder of Wikipedia ironic absurd
interesting important
um what are your comments so I would say
unimportant
um not that interesting I mean one of
the things that uh people are sometimes
surprised to hear me say is I actually
think Larry Sanger doesn't get enough
credit for his early work in Wikipedia
even though I think co-founder is not
the right title for that so you know
like he had a lot of impact and a lot of
uh great work and I disagree with a lot
of things since and all that and that's
fine so yeah no to me that's like
it's one of these things that
the media love a falling out story so
they want to make a big deal out of it
and I'm just like yeah
so there's a lot of interesting
engineering contributions in the early
days like you were saying there's
debates about how to structure it what
the heck is this thing that we're doing
and there's important people that
contributed to that yeah definitely uh
so he also you said you've had some
disagreements Larry Sanger said that
nobody should trust Wikipedia
and then Wikipedia seems to assume that
there's only one legitimate defensible
version of the truth on any
controversial question that's not how
Wikipedia used to be I presume you
disagree with that analysis let me just
straight up I disagree like go and read
any Wikipedia entry on a controversial
topic and what you'll see is a really
diligent effort to explain all the
relevant sides so yeah just disagree so
uncontroversial questions you think
perspectives are generally represented I
mean because it has to do with the kind
of the tension between the mainstream
and the uh
non-mainstream that we're talking about
yeah no I mean for sure
um like to take
this area of uh discussion seriously is
to say yeah you know what actually that
is a big part of what wikipedians spend
their time grappling with is to say you
know how do we figure out
um whether a
less popular View
is pseudoscience is it just a less
popular view that's gaining Acceptance
in the mainstream is it Fringe versus
crackpot etc etc and that debate is what
you've got to do there's no choice about
having that debate of grappling with
something
um and I think we do and I think that's
really important and I think if anybody
said uh to the Wikipedia community
G you should stop you know sort of
covering minority viewpoints uh on this
issue I think they would say I don't
even understand why you would say that
like we have to sort of grapple with
minority viewpoints in science and
politics and so on
um but it's and and like this is one of
the reasons why you know there is no
magic simple answer to all these things
it's really uh
contextual it's Case by case it's like
you know you've got to really say okay
what is the context here how do you do
it and and you've always got to be open
to correction and to change and to sort
of Challenge and always be sort of
serious about that and then what happens
again with social media is when when
there is that grappling process in
Wikipedia and a decision is made to
remove a paragraph or to remove a thing
or to say a thing you're going to notice
of the one One Direction of the
oscillation of the grappling and not the
correction and you're going to highlight
that and say how did how come this
person yeah um I don't know I wouldn't
maybe uh legitimacy of Elections that's
the thing that comes up Donald Trump
maybe
I can give a really good example which
is there was this sort of dust up about
the definition of recession in Wikipedia
so the accusation was and the accusation
was often quite ridiculous and extreme
which is under pressure from the Biden
Administration Wikipedia changed the
definition of recession to make Biden
look good or we did it not under
pressure but because we're a bunch of
lunatic leftists and so on and then you
know when I see something like that in
the Press I'm like oh dear like what's
happened here how do we do that because
I always just accept things for five
seconds first and then I go and I look
and I'm like you know what that's
literally completely not what happened
what happened was one editor thought the
article needed restructuring so the
article is always said so the the
traditional kind of loose definition of
recession is two quarters of negative
growth but there's always been within
economics within important agencies in
different countries around the world a
lot of nuance around that and there's
other like factors that go into it and
so forth and it's just an interesting
complicated topic
and so the article has always had the
definition of two quarters the only
thing that really changed was moving
that from the lead from the top
paragraph to further down and then news
stories appeared saying uh Wikipedia has
changed the definition of recession and
then we got a huge rush of trolls coming
in so the article was temporarily
protected I think only semi-protected
and people were told go to the talk Pace
to discuss so it was a dust up that was
you know when you look at it as a
Wikipedia and you're like oh like this
is a really routine kind of editorial
debate another example which
unfortunately our friend Elon fell for I
would say is that the Twitter files so
there was an article called the Twitter
files which is about these files that
were released once Elon took control of
Twitter and he released internal
documents and the what happened was
somebody nominated it for deletion but
even the nomination said
this is actually
this is mainly about the hunter Biden
laptop controversy shouldn't this
information be there instead so anyone
can like it takes exactly one human
being anywhere on the planet to propose
something for deletion and that triggers
a process where people discuss it which
within a few hours it was what we call
snowball closed I.E this doesn't have a
snowball's chance and Hell of of passing
so an admin goes yeah wrong and closed
the debate and that was it that was the
whole thing that happened
um and so nobody proposed suppressing
the information nobody suppose it wasn't
important it was just like editorally
boring internal question
and you know so sometimes people read
stuff like that and they're like oh you
see look at these leftists they're
trying to suppress the truth again it's
like well slow down a second and come
and look like literally it's not what
happened
yes I think the right is more sensitive
to censorship
uh and so yeah they will more likely
uh highlight there's more virality to
highlighting something that looks like
censorship in any walks of life and this
moving a paragraph from one place to
another removing it and so on as part of
the regular grappling of Wikipedia can
make a hell of a good article a YouTube
video yeah yeah no it sounds really uh
enticing and intriguing and surprising
to most people because they're like
I'm reading Wikipedia doesn't seem like
a crackpot leftist website it seems
pretty
kind of dull really in its own geeky way
well so that makes a good story it's
like oh am I being misled because
there's a shadowy cabal of Jimmy Wales
you know I generally I read political
stuff I mentioned to you that I'm
um traveling to uh
uh have some very difficult conversation
with high profile figures both in the
war and Ukraine and in Israel and
Palestine
and
you know I read the Wikipedia articles
around that and
I also read books on the conflict and
the history of the different regions and
I find the Wikipedia articles to be very
balanced and there's many perspectives
being represented but then I asked
myself well am I one of them left this
crackpots
they can't see the truth I mean it's
something I ask myself all the time
forget the leftists just crackpotting am
I am I just being a sheep
and accepting it I think that's an
important question to always ask but not
yet too much yeah no I agree a little
bit right but not too much no I think we
always have to challenge ourselves of
like what what do I potentially have
wrong